when you see this spak movement
happening
um and so a lot of the companies i
invest in privately are
are being pursued by specs some of them
seem to be run
by really um
[Music]
um you know people with great track
records in their careers
and then some of these people have never
heard of
and then the quality of the companies
seems variable do you think we need more
public companies in general so there's
more
inventory of companies because we have
half the number of publicly complete
traded companies than we had
i think it was 15 years ago do you think
it would be good for us to have some
more publicly traded companies and
stacks and then
again you're not going to give financial
advice but
obviously invest what you can afford to
lose and then these would be more
speculative right so
the risk reward would be they're coming
out earlier
therefore there's more risk therefore
there's potentially more return
is are spax a net positive
for the vibrant economic system
of capitalism and democracy in the
united states well
people are looking for different ways
for companies to go public and the
special acquisition corporation is
is one iteration so essentially you give
money to people who say
um who say okay we're gonna go find a
great public company and we'll
put it into this essentially this
special purpose acquisition company
which is
an empty shell in a way and you can put
any private company in and then it's
it's a public company um and so that's
that
has existed for quite some time but for
some reason of late has gotten quite a
bit of attention
and has become somewhat of a
some there there's somewhat of a trend
of these happening now
in general i i do think that we want to
make our public markets as attractive
of a place as possible so that more
companies want to go public
earlier because
there are a number of reasons why the
number of public companies has fallen in
the united states and you ask
different people and they have different
theories about that but
one of the things that we've been trying
to work on at the sec recently is to
make it
less burdensome to be a public company
and not in the way
you know we're not compromising investor
protection but we're saying where
they're duplicative rules
that we can streamline let's let's take
care of that
let's think about ways to make new
public companies
trade easier sometimes you go public
with the idea that oh you're going to
trade just like
one of the biggest tech companies trades
you know lots of liquidity
it doesn't really work like that so can
we can we
maybe create some special ways for these
newly public companies to trade
can we think about um you know what the
other
causes are for example there's not as
much research analyst coverage for new
public companies
so there there are a lot of different
ways to attack this
this um problem and i think we're we're
trying to think about those now
um but the the the idea that people are
are being innovative in the way that
they take companies public is good i
would just
again without giving investment advice i
would just give the general
the general thing i've been trying to
hammer home which is do your research
you know look at who's who's running
this back and and what how they're going
to get paid
um and those are things that you should
think about before you invest
incentives certainly matter uh you know
my friend chamath has been
he kind of brought this smack thing back
chamath is putting when you want to talk
about skin in the game and the
seem to lab kind of way i mean
chamath is putting tens of millions of
dollars of his own money into each one
of these
therefore you know he doesn't want to
lose that there's a massive amount of
skin in the game